welcome to cloud security basics a new
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application on Google
cloud sound fun then stick around
because in this episode you'll learn how
google cloud protects customers data
[Music]
hello cloud detective you may have
answered basic questions about platform
security but what do you know about how
Google clouds occurs data inside of its
platform as you hit Send on your
keyboard and send data over the network
what if my hench people could intercept
that data or I could plant malware
inside of your system did it variously
do my bidding what can you do to stop
that for your sake I hope you know the
answer to my question okay here's what
we know this comes down to securing data
at rest and securing data in transit
when Brad actor talks about a malicious
service inside of your system gaining
access to your other services there are
a lot of ways Google protects from that
for one to keep data private and secure
Google logically isolates each
customer's data from that of other
customers and users even when is stored
on the same physical server as Google is
managing this data for its cloud clients
it protects them from employees abusing
their access only a small group of
Google employees ever have access to
customer data
additionally Google doesn't scan
customer data for advertisements or sell
it to third parties and then if
customers delete their data Google
commits to deleting it from their
systems within 180 days finally Google
provides tools that make it easy for
customers to take their data with them
if they ever choose to stop using Google
services these are just a few examples
of how Google cloud protects customer
data that lives in Google cloud let's
look at a few more so how does Google
cloud protect from data being
intercepted as it's sent over the
network before we answer that let's talk
about data at rest when users store
their data in Google cloud the various
Google storage services can be
configured to use keys from a central
key management service to encrypt data
before it's written to physical storage
performing encryption at the application
layer allows the infrastructure to
isolate itself from potential threats at
the lower levels of stories such as a
malicious discs firmware other layers of
protections are also used such as
hardware encryption
but once data leaves Google secure
server customer data must make several
journeys across devices known as hops
across the public Internet
the number of hops depends on the
distance between the customer's ISP and
the solutions data center each
additional hop introduces a new
opportunity for data to be attacked or
intercepted because it's linked to the
most ISPs in the world though Google's
global network improves the security of
data in transit by limiting hops across
the public Internet all traffic is
routed through custom Google front end
servers Google front end servers were
used to detect and stop malicious
requests and distributed denial of
service attacks
additionally GFE servers are only
allowed to communicate with the control
list of servers internally this default
deny configuration prevents GFE servers
from accessing unintended resources as
the data moves along the network google
uses cryptography to ensure the data is
private unchanged by any third party and
is being exchanged between trusted
partners these cryptographic features
are encapsulated inside of the Google
Cloud RPC mechanisms so they're
available to other application layer
protocols such as HTTP this provides
application layer isolation and removes
dependency on the security of the
network path encrypted inter-service
communication can remain secure even if
the network is tapped or a network
device compromised on top of that google
uses industry standard firewalls and
access control lists or ackles to ensure
Network segregation adding another layer
of protection to sensitive networks
lastly since Google's using the same
infrastructure provides to its users the
same DDoS and man-in-the-middle
protections we talked about previously
apply here which means I know the answer
to brad actors question hello detective
I see you've been busy and solve my
little question once data is stored in
Google's data centers what's keeping it
safe very good you found the crux of the
argument
google has protections in place to store
data in transit and data at rest data
stored on Google server is only ever
accessed by a Google employee on a
need-to-know basis
once data leaves Google's data centers
there are a few tools Google puts in
place to protect customers data click
custom networking hardware inter-service
encryption and Inter service ACLs very
good very good
you've answered today's question but are
you ready because next time I want to
see how your platform handles physical
security so that's it another episode of
cloud security basics next episode will
focus on how Google cloud secures the
data centers and hardware in the
meantime if you want to take a deeper
dive and how Google secures its users
customer data then check out the article
linked in the description below stay
tuned for the rest of the cloud security
basics series because when it comes to
security you can't let bad actors win
[Music]